[Aplausos]
las caras no mienten la paz es la mejor
ciudad del mundo
hace un par de años el colectivo tomate
nos visitó en esta ciudad era un grupo
de artistas que venían con sueños con
intenciones con colores con su arte
venían vinieron y llenaron esta ciudad
de color nos recordaron que la calle es
nuestra
de algún lado tenía que sacar sus
historias las historias ya vivían aquí
eran las historias de cada uno de
ustedes eran las historias de la paz
eran historias de amor de perseverancia
de cotidianidad de extraordinario nes
extraordinarias
yo siempre he creído que soy una mujer
muy afortunada y a mí me tocó estar en
uno de esos encuentros en los que estos
artistas se nutrieron de la vida y de
las historias de los paseños
en particular me tocó una mañana estar
en ese lugar en el barrio del manguito
déjenme detenerme un momento para
platicarles por qué es especial este
lugar
la paz literalmente nació de el manglito
y del espíritu la paz nació de la pesca
la paz es mar las calles de la paz saben
amar huelen a mal puede correr el mar
por cada uno de los rincones de esta
ciudad
en el manglito habitan personas
extraordinarias hombres y mujeres que
tienen una conexión muy particular con
sus recursos con sus costas con sus
mares pescadores buzos excepcionales que
de las profundidades del mar sacan
alimento para cada uno de nosotros
han sido tan buenos pescadores que con
el tiempo acabaron con una de sus
pesquerías principales con el callo de
hacha de la ensenada de la paz
tomo mucho valor tomo mucho esfuerzo
tomo muchas lágrimas y tomo mucho empeño
y mucha fe para poder restaurar esa
ensenada para lograr después de siete
años volver a recuperar una pesquería
vibrante que en este momento mientras
ustedes y yo estamos aquí ellos están
sacando este este tipo de moluscos de la
ensenada
para que después todos podamos comernos
algo que se parece a esto
quiero regresar a esa mañana de domingo
cuando estábamos sentados con los
artistas
ese día el insee que está ahí que está
ahí junto a su abuelo
estaba participando en el círculo
lynch y es una niña normalmente muy
participativa pero esa mañana había
estado callada yo tampoco entendía muy
bien por qué
recuerdo que le invite a participar yo
quería que contara quién es ese señor
que está a su lado el chiflo el chiflo
es un pescador y el chiflo es un
filósofo el chiflo fue el hombre que me
enseñó que para restaurar los
ecosistemas marinos para restaurar la
vida en este planeta primero tenemos que
restaurar nos a cada uno de nosotros y
yo quería que el insee dijera eso
entonces le pregunté link sino quieres
compartir con estos artistas quién es tu
abuelo
y ese par de ojos negros hermosísimos
que están ahí se abrieron
y en algún momento lynch y se levantó y
declaró mi abuelo es un restaurador del
mar
yo creo que en ese momento lynch y como
suelen hacerlo muchos niños estaba
inaugurando un nuevo idioma estaba
pintando una nueva realidad estaba
poniéndole palabras aún a un futuro que
ya estaba emergiendo
y algo de este calibre
no puede dejarlo uno pasar nada más así
porque si yo ya tenía bastantes años
trabajando con esta comunidad pero fue
necesaria una reflexión en torno a lo
que le había pasado a ese grupo de
mujeres y de hombres que habían
transformado su realidad con tanta
potencia había que pensar porque una
niña estaba inaugurando nuevos idiomas
había que pensar también que me había
pasado a mí
yo no tengo la sabiduría que tiene el
insee ni la sabiduría que tienen las
niñas
voy a tomar una serie de ideas y una
serie de conceptos que otras personas
han trabajado para tratar de hacer
sentido de lo que ha pasado en el
manglito y el primer elemento que quiero
ofrecerles es el concepto de la
autoorganización el poder del gran
círculo la capacidad humana nata de
sentarnos de mirarnos unos a otros de
hablar de las verdaderas cosas que
importan y de actuar juntos como tribu
en colectivo este es un poder que a los
mexicanos se nos ha olvidado pero ahí lo
tenemos solo basta sentarse cambiar la
estructura en la que normalmente nos
hablamos y empezar a habitar el gran
círculo
es en esos espacios en estos espacios
tan abundantes donde también se desata
una danza pensemos en esto como una
especie de baile esto ocurre en los
círculos es el baile de la acción y el
baile de la reflexión el baile de
atrevernos a pensar a soñar a poder
vernos voltear el espejo hacia nosotros
saber cómo hemos sido nosotros los que
hemos construido el sistema que
habitamos y nosotros los que lo podemos
transformar si repetimos este baile una
y otra vez habitando el gran círculo
cosas impresionantes pueden ocurrir pero
sobre todo ocurre el aprendizaje
de donde sacamos la energía para estas
acciones de donde sacamos la energía
para sentarnos y atrevernos a pensar y
hacer diferentes
podemos crearla nosotros mismos para eso
tenemos que ser muy fieles con nuestra
realidad para eso tenemos que aprender a
ver nuestra realidad en nuestra realidad
lo bueno lo malo lo brillante lo que
duele lo que muere entender y observar y
admirar la realidad con todas sus
tonalidades y desde ese lugar bien
plantados trazar un sueño muy alto
porque como estamos lejos de él lo que
vamos a causar extensión la tensión es
energía es capacidad de movernos es
capacidad de soñar esta es una obra de
arte que hicieron los niños del manguito
en 2011 lo que les pregunto el artista
que les ayudó a hacer esta obra fue que
hay en la ensenada de la paz y ellos
vieron orcas vieron tiburones vieron
ballenas y por ahí hasta un pulpo
gigante ahí
la verdad es que nada de eso existía en
ese momento en ensenada no existe ahora
y les preguntamos eso no está ahí y
ellos dijeron no pero eso estuvo una vez
ahí eso nos contaron los abuelos
existían y por eso vamos a trabajar y
como ustedes ya lo saben la utopía sirve
es justamente para eso para levantarse y
caminar
el cuarto elemento que quiero compartir
con ustedes hoy es el liderazgo
colectivo
estamos en un momento en que tenemos que
aceptar que el liderazgo es de todas o
es de todos o no es liderazgo
esta es una imagen muy mala de un día
muy bello este día los pescadores del
manguito se dieron cuenta cómo podían
cambiar la idea que tenían de ellos
mismos
eso se llama cambiar la cultura y quien
transforma la cultura es capaz de
transformar al mundo eso hicieron ese
día cuando además de verse como
pescadores como los mejores pescadores
que existen también se convirtieron en
custodios de sus recursos naturales y
defendieron con sus voces con sus
cuerpos con su movimiento los callos que
hay están creciendo
y yo sé yo sé que para este momento
muchos de ustedes deben estar pensando
que esto es demasiado ambiguo o
demasiado simple o demasiado incómodo
yo también lo creo y lo creo varias
veces
la cosa es que he visto milagros suceder
he visto cosas que jamás pensé que iba a
ver y esta es una de ellas
esta es comida esto da vida esto nació
de una ensenada que estaba muerta esto
ha alimentado a personas
he visto como los jóvenes del manguito
se convierten en cineastas y se mueven
de todos santos a monterrey a las salas
de cine de la paz para mostrar su arte
ahí en medio está josecito quien
probablemente sea el cineasta más joven
que existe hoy en baja california sur
director productor protagonista de un
documental bellísimo y lo mismo hicieron
todos los demás que están ahí
yo también creería que todo esto es muy
simple si no fuera porque esas tres
mujeres andrea cell y marta se levantan
todos los días a las 5 de la mañana para
recordarle a alguno que quiera ir a
sacar los callos los callos de hacha de
la ensenada que esos callos tienen
dueños caminan por todo el manglar
vigilando lo que tanto esfuerzo le ha
costado a su comunidad de hacer crecer
pero en épocas recientes aprendí que no
solo hacen eso la gente que camina por
ahí y si alguno de ustedes las ha visto
o si alguno de ustedes las quiere
conocer ya empezó a reconocer en ellas
las verdaderas custodias de ese espacio
público me cuentan que la gente está
regresando a correr porque se sienten
cuidados por ellas me cuentan que la
gente está llevando cada vez más ahí a
sus mascotas porque se sienten seguros
me cuentan que la gente va a observar
aves ahí y les preguntan qué es lo que
están viendo
eso se llama recuperación de espacios
públicos eso es lo que va a cambiar a
este país porque en muy pocos lugares
está ocurriendo ellas tres lo están
haciendo realidad
kelly se encarga todos los días de que
todas las hachas que se sacan de la
ensenada sean registradas ella está
revisando que sea una pesquería
sustentable que sea una pesquería
confiable junto con otras mujeres que
están dando el ejemplo de lo que
necesita este país hoy en día
y esta es mi favorita
quiero ser honesta también con ustedes
no todo es perfecto en el manglito les
falta mucho a mi me gusta verlos como
una comunidad en desarrollo me gusta
verlo como hombres y mujeres otra vez
que aprendieron a contarse un nuevo
cuento sobre ellos y que actúan en base
a esa nueva historia les falta un montón
pero ahí hay hombres y mujeres
trabajando codo a codo hombres que
reconocen el valor de las mujeres
mujeres que encuentran en los hombres
los compañeros que necesitan para poder
juntos rescatar su comunidad aquí es
donde se está gestando un nuevo modo de
trabajar juntos
que quiero decirles con todo eso
la verdad es que no hay nada en el
manglito que sea diferente a lo que hay
en cada una de sus colonias
los men desde el manglito no son
diferentes de cada uno de ustedes
son mexicanos comunes y corrientes
todavía tienen mucho trabajo que hacer
pero haciendo cosas diferentes
reflexionando colaborando siendo
vulnerables aprendiendo están
transformando su realidad con resultados
muy concretos
tengo una propuesta para ustedes
la paz
es la mejor ciudad del mundo si la
habitamos si salimos si nos sentamos si
nos tomamos de las manos unos a otros y
empezamos a hablar de las cosas que
verdaderamente importan nuestros niños
que estamos haciendo con nuestra basura
cómo está de limpia o no limpia nuestra
agua estamos vigilando que están
haciendo nuestros representantes salimos
a votar nos comprometemos con lo que
está pasando
hagámoslo nunca desaprovecha la
oportunidad de formar un círculo pequeño
que después enlace con otro y con otro y
con otro hasta que habitemos el gran
círculo en el que podamos restaurar y
ser restauradas en el que podamos sanar
y ser sanadores en el que podamos
habitar
el mejor lugar
desde el mejor lugar independientemente
de la ciudad en la que nos haya tocado
vivir que tengan una excelente tarde
[Aplausos]